I love you I didn't feel it okay it's
fine
unhelpful helpful advice with Bobby at
Cavallo
Haislip King & Company and Queen I'm a
20 year old guy from England and I've
been dating a 26 year old lady for the
past five months it's even on and off
hard times but recently the hard times
have been more frequent she recently
threw a rope at me and told me to hang
myself I took it for the fact that she's
an ass when she drinks whiskey the next
day she apologized and everything was
good then she accused me of a wanting to
[ __ ] someone off Instagram I've never
met and I have since found out she's
recently been messaging her ex I'm in
love with this girl and I want to go on
but I'm scared of the future big love to
all what do I do
boundaries no maybe not this first set
boundaries during a rope no it's like
she was drunk what she did it right so
hey hey sweetie next time you drink and
you say [ __ ] like that
I'm done yep I'm [ __ ] done I'll give
you that pass right yep you gotta set
boundaries for yourself and she crosses
the line that it means she doesn't
respect you and [ __ ] move on she also
doesn't seem like she seems very
insecure she just seems really unsteady
well there's two things well you can't
really say someone's unsteady just based
on like three sentences three sentences
but if you're the younger one by six
years and you're able to recognize that
someone a woman no less because usually
women tend to emotionally mature a
little bit faster than men hmm the fact
that you're 20 and you're seeing this 26
woman come unhinged like that you know
that's to me that's really concerning
that's messy and because you're only 20
no kids big future ahead I say drop it
you'll fall in love deeper and harder
many more times I mean that's unhealthy
I tell people they're not stick around
for stuff like that I make kalila when I
was 42 if I would have stuck with the
nobody girl that I was with with 20
there wasn't one
Ryan
but let's see 23 I met a girl I did if I
would have stuck with her I mean and I
had the feelings for her
take deep love I bet it was love at
first yeah deep deep blue my but if I
would have done that my life would have
turned such a different direction it
would have gone this way yeah I think
it's good to feel all those things
you're feeling date as many people fall
in love throw you put yourself in there
don't put up these walls just because
people hurt you or try not to allow
yourself all the growth possible and
fall in love over and over again but
don't keep putting yourself in
situations where it's like emotionally
unhealthy that to me is crazy
telling someone to go [ __ ] kill
themselves mmm that ain't right she is
she ain't right she's not right but even
in my drunkest angriest moment I went
through a rope with someone yeah like if
she threw a rope to you at you like last
month and said oh if she did that so I'm
saying oh she did that to me one time
regardless that's out that's end game so
damn that's so crazy
dangerous if I would throw if honestly
if I threw a rope at you and go go hang
yourself I go hang myself just so you
can sleep for the rest of your life yeah
but a rope you would leave you would
leave right of course yeah that's crazy
yeah leave it yeah anything to the
people the sleepers I already did it
okay any final words of the first I
already did it 20 to 20 20
yeah we're using into it I